the core body temperatures meant to be
37 mine went down to 28 my heart could
have very easily stopped
in planes the football sense or three
years old say it's not just a sport for
me it's potentially could be my career
in the future
I don't always enjoy training in fact
they wouldn't be normal if you always
enjoyed is there a lot of sacrifice when
I want to go for something I go for it I
don't be like while do it tomorrow I'll
do it next week is on 25th December I
almost didn't have it tomorrow
your story day walking from doorless to
Timur
there's a higher part of the wall you
can walk on to we decided to walk on the
lower part I flies invincible I thought
it's never gonna happen to me I look to
my left as a massive wave picks me up
smashes me against the seawall
another way picks me back up not you
onto the wall
the count was way too strong I remember
just being stuck in the backwash it was
horrible
as we were heading down towards gray
point I could see a young lad on the
wall pointing to somebody in the water I
was just one particular way it crashed
right on top of me and it sent me
straight on that we knew time was
against us the thoughts that went
through my head with my mom my dad and
my brother we just grabbed hold of him
onto the boat I worked with in and out
consciousness they got ready to commence
CPR and as I looked forward there was
just wall of water coming towards the
boat
every mother's worst nightmare isn't it
to lose a child
I'm hoping to make a career in football
obviously being offered a scholarship to
go and play in California me and my
girlfriend I expecting a little baby I
was lucky enough to have a second chance
you know what now how big or strong
y'all no matter how amazing you think
you are once you up to that water you're
at the water's mercy
[Music]